hey everyone it's sarah redston nurse  rn.com and i want to talk to you about  rolling veins so here is a classic  example of a rolling vein so you look at  these veins they look beautiful like i  want to stick this for an iv right  well look at this vein he has a little  secret he likes to roll like whenever i  touch him look at how he rolls like that  so whenever i go  to poke him if i  stuck him in this same position for an  iv whenever my needle went to penetrate  the skin this vein would just go  to the side and say you're not sticking  me  so what can you do whenever you're  starting iv to help decrease that from  happening well you can have a patient  make a fist  and then right before you stick just  gently pull down that skin right here  and then stick and then watch  he doesn't roll he is stabilized and he  is mine to be poked so that is a quick  tip to hopefully help you with starting  ivs